donald trump campaigned in 2016 on
ending america's wars abroad
in the final days of his presidency he's
acting to cut numbers in both iraq and
afghanistan
from 4500 in afghanistan the number will
drop to 2500.
it'll be the same number in iraq where
there are currently more than three
thousand personnel
this is consistent with our established
plans and strategic
objectives supported by the american
people
and does not equate to a change in u.s
policy
or objectives
afghanistan is the us's longest war it's
lasted 19 years
more than 2 300 soldiers have died it's
cost
more than 193 billion dollars
earlier this year the u.s with the help
of qatar negotiated a deal with the
afghan taliban
to bring a permanent ceasefire and
remove all foreign forces out of the
country
by may next year in october donald trump
tweeted he wanted all u.s service
personnel home by christmas
december 25th what he's leaving biden
is something that again in the long run
is probably where we
would have ended up with eventually
anyway but the timing is seen as very
rash and dangerous
donald trump has announced troop
withdrawals in the past
famously tweeting in 2018 that he wanted
all u.s service personnel out of syria
that announcement led
in part to the resignation of then
defense secretary
jim mattis the military slo-rolled that
idea then
but it's clear that donald trump wants
the troops out
and on the timetable he's announced
but the decision has brought criticism
even from his own side
president barack obama pulled troops out
of iraq just before the end of his time
in office
honoring an agreement and a deadline set
by his republican predecessor
but republicans claim that move led to
the growth of isil
a risk one senator says trump is taking
now
i think it's extremely important here in
the next couple of months
not to have any earth-shaking changes
with regard to defense and foreign
policy
i think a precipitous drawdown in either
afghanistan or iraq would be a mistake
the head of nato has warned of a quick
uncoordinated withdrawal
saying it risks lives but it's clear
donald trump wants to leave office
claiming another campaign promise has
been delivered
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house